Traduttore: Riccardo Fraccaro
Revisore: Tatiana Zavanelli
Ho portato due dadi con me:
uno è un comune dado con sei facce,
numerate dall'1 al 6.
L'altro è un dado con 10 facce.
Se lo lancio,
qualsiasi valore dall'1 al 10
ha la stessa probabilità di uscire.
Ora giochiamo: voi lanciate il dado
da 10 facce, io quello da 6.
Vincete a questo gioco se ottenete
un numero uguale o più grande del mio.
Sette a cinque!
Complimenti avete vinto la giocata!
Vincere con il dado da 10 facce
è più facile, ma sapreste dirmi,
approssimativamente, qual è la vostra
probabilità di vincere a questo gioco?
Un possibile approccio
si basa sull'esperienza.
Vi spiego: posso lanciare ripetutamente
i dadi e prendere nota di ogni vittoria.
Dopo 100 lanci, mi renderei conto
di vincere all'incirca
7 o 8 volte ogni giocata.
Con un po' di pazienza e 1000 lanci,
capirei che la probabilità di
vittoria si avvicina al 75%.
Con l'aumentare dei lanci,
la mia stima, basata sulla media
dei successi, diventa più precisa.
Questo, oltre a essere intuitivo,
è garantito dalla legge dei grandi numeri.
Poi, se ritenete un po' tedioso
lanciare dei dadi 1000 volte,
possiamo farlo fare a un computer.
Il vostro portatile dovrebbe riuscire
a lanciare all'incirca
100 milioni di dadi in un solo secondo.
Questo tipo di approccio
a un problema matematico,
alla risoluzione di un
problema matematico,
si chiama "Metodo Montecarlo",
proprio per la capacità del computer
di simulare il caso.
È un metodo potentissimo.
Possiamo simulare un lancio dei dadi,
ma anche il comportamento di un fluido,
oppure l'evoluzione di una colonia
di batteri o di un'epidemia
o addirittura l'andamento
di interi sistemi finanziari.
Per dare risposta al gioco dei dadi,
non abbiamo avuto bisogno
di nessuna matematica.
Un matematico puro riterrebbe
il metodo Montecarlo poco elegante,
come se avessimo abusato
della forza bruta dell'informatica.
A me sembra piuttosto una forma di magia!
E per questo, 4 anni fa ho iniziato
il mio dottorato in "Metodi Montecarlo"
all'università di Warwick, in Inghilterra.
Ora ripongo i dadi.
Non voglio parlarvi di matematica oggi.
Voglio raccontarvi
un capitolo della mia storia.
Purtroppo, la magia dei metodi Montecarlo,
che mi aveva tanto stregato,
è svanita dopo la prima
settimana di dottorato!
L'ambiente di lavoro a Warwick
è eccezionale: ho un mio ufficio,
un super computer, seminari e conferenze
sono all'ordine del giorno
e i 2 professori che mi seguono
sono di un'intelligenza,
competenza e umanità impareggiabili!
Ma il dottorato non fa per tutti.
Il dottorato è estremamente difficile,
tecnico, spesso frustrante,
poiché è basato sulla ricerca innovativa.
Dietro a ogni idea vincente
ci sono 10, 100 tentativi falliti.
Il dottorato può essere
un percorso solitario.
Io passo la maggior parte
del mio tempo da solo,
di fronte al computer
o a un articolo di statistica.
Per affrontare questi ostacoli,
serve una passione solidissima,
di cui io non ero provvisto!
Menti in Movimento, sembra un tema
servito su un piatto d'argento
per un matematico che studia all'estero,
ma vi posso garantire che in quel momento,
la mia mente era più che ferma, paralizzata!
Pochi mesi dopo l'inizio del dottorato,
ho iniziato a insegnare.
Ero così teso!
Pensate:
insegnare matematica... e in inglese!
Per la prima lezione di 40 minuti.
mi sono preparato per più di 2 settimane!
Ma, con quella prima lezione,
si accendeva un fuoco dentro di me,
di determinazione, motivazione, finalità,
tutto quello che prima mancava!
E per quale motivo?
Perché tutta quella euforia?
Non mi interessava
rispondere a questa domanda.
Mi sentivo rigenerato,
volevo mantenere questo stato di euforia!
E così, mi ci sono buttato a capofitto.
Ho iniziato a vivere
di lezione in lezione,
Non mi bastava una preparazione solida,
volevo appassionare i miei studenti,
coinvolgerli, sorprenderli
e... farli divertire!
Cercavo di sfruttare ogni opportunità!
Ho ottenuto un diploma
in didattica universitaria,
sono passato da insegnare
da due ore a studenti del primo anno
a più di 8 ore a studenti
dei corsi più avanzati.
Maggiore era il carico di lavoro, più
diventavo efficiente, forte, determinato.
E poi per me non si trattava di lavoro!
Trovo realizzazione
in ogni aspetto dell'insegnamento.
Preparare la lezione è un processo
creativo, stimolante, una forma d'arte.
Mi piace perfino correggere i compiti!
Leggere le idee degli studenti,
giuste o sbagliate che siano,
porta a un apprendimento continuo!
E poi, beh, c'è il momento
della performance!
In classe divento uno showman
e l'aula è il mio palcoscenico.
La lezione è il mio spettacolo.
La gratitudine degli studenti
ripagava ampiamente tutta la mia fatica!
E io stavo imparando da loro,
quanto loro stavano imparando da me!
Nel corso del terzo anno,
arriva anche un riconoscimento concreto.
L'università di Warwick
mi assegna il premio
per l'eccellenza nell'insegnamento
come giovane ricercatore.
Nel corso del mio dottorato,
ho ottenuto tante soddisfazioni,
ma questa risuonava dentro di me
in maniera diversa!
Era stato tutto così naturale,
bello, avvincente.
Nel mio piccolo, stavo sperimentando
qualcosa che vale in larga scala!
Il modo più autentico e genuino
per raggiungere successo e realizzazione
è mettere a frutto le proprie passioni.
A quel punto, ho riguardato indietro
a tutto quello che era successo
in così poco tempo,
fino ad arrivare a quella domanda
del primo giorno di lezione, vi ricordate?
Perché? Qual è il motivo
di tutta questa euforia?
Quel fuoco,
quell'esplosione di determinazione?
La risposta che mi sono dato
è insita nel mio modo di essere
e nei valori con cui sono cresciuto,
nei valori con cui
tutti noi siamo cresciuti!
È la cultura della condivisione!
Ci sono degli oggetti
o dei beni in senso astratto che,
se vengono spartiti tra più persone,
invece di svalutarsi, acquisiscono valore!
Un concerto, il TED, questo evento,
una canzone, un libro, un viaggio,
oppure un'esperienza, un'opinione,
anche un momento di silenzio!
Una passione, un talento, la felicità!
Tra questi beni, c'è anche la conoscenza.
Avevo ritrovato il valore,
la passione per la conoscenza,
nella condivisione della conoscenza!
E la mia mente si era messa in movimento,
proprio nel momento in cui avevo cercato
di mettere in movimento
le menti dei miei studenti!
In Inghilterra è stata
un'esperienza fantastica!
Ora sto scrivendo la mia tesi di dottorato
e conto di finirla nei prossimi mesi.
È quasi il momento
di decidere il mio prossimo passo.
Come avrete capito, la passione
per l'insegnamento è grandiosa
L'università, però, non è l'unico luogo
in cui matematica
e comunicazione s'incontrano
per dare vita a questa magia
della condivisione della conoscenza.
Ma staremo a vedere!
Vi ho raccontato
questo capitolo della mia storia
proprio perché penso che ciò
che ho imparato sia condivisibile.
Metodi Montecarlo a parte, per esempio,
il fatto di intraprendere un percorso
che poi non si rivela quello che credevamo
oppure trovare finalità e motivazione
attraverso strade
che non ci eravamo aspettati!
E poi, certo, la passione
come catalizzatore dei nostri talenti
e la cultura della condivisione!
C'è un'ultima cosa
che voglio condividere con voi,
e per farlo, vi invito a lezione!
È una lezione di preparazione
all'esame di finanza.
Ci sono più di 100 studenti in aula.
Io entro di buon umore,
mi dirigo alla cattedra
sistemo bene il microfono
e sfodero i miei tre pennarelli colorati.
Allo scoccare dell'ora, mi schiarisco la voce.
C'è già silenzio.
Spiego che l'esercitazione
che ho preparato ci permetterà
di passare tutti i punti chiave del corso.
Una ragazza in prima fila
mi chiede se posso dare
qualche indizio sulle domande d'esame.
Io l'esame non l'ho visto,
ma ho passato il sabato notte
a rivedere gli esami dei 5 anni passati,
ho raccolto tutto quello
che possono aspettarsi su uno schema.
Lo potranno avere a fine lezione.
Un altro ragazzo,
un po' più indietro, mi chiede
dove può trovare
altri esercizi per prepararsi.
È vero, abbiamo avuto
poco tempo per la pratica,
ma c'è molto materiale in internet
e dove trovarlo
l'ho scritto sul retro dello schema!
Sono soddisfatti.
Bene, inizia lo show!
Io scrivo alla lavagna,
ma spesso mi rivolgo a loro
per chiedere come procedere.
Ogni punto della pratica,
richiama un elemento di teoria
che ripassiamo tutti quanti assieme.
Qualcuno fa una domanda,
acuta, molto difficile,
ma io ho passato la domenica
sul loro libro di testo,
sono ben preparato, me la cavo.
Scherzo con loro
per fargli prendere respiro
e l'ora di lezione vola!
Gli faccio l'in bocca al lupo per l'esame.
Un gruppo di studenti si ferma,
qualcuno chiede dei chiarimenti,
ma la maggior parte
solo delle rassicurazioni.
Un ultimo studente mi si avvicina.
Gli sorrido.
Lui esita nel parlare, sembra straniero,
forse sta cercando le parole giuste.
Alla fine, trova il coraggio
solo per dirmi:
"Pier, io voglio solo dirti grazie!
Perché quello che tu fai per noi,
non lo fa nessuno!"
Rimango solo in aula,
e ho un sorriso immenso
e un cuore ancora più gigante!
E penso che forse è proprio quello
il mio posto a questo mondo!
Ecco, questo voglio dirvi:
mente e cuore sono legati saldamente
e per questo motivo,
quando la mente è in movimento
anche il cuore
vi batte forte dentro il petto!
Sono mente e cuore in movimento!
Grazie!
(Applausi)